Jen it's great to see you here in Los
Angeles I feel like we've we've been
seeing each other from across the water
uh often in very quite tense and fractur
circumstances with big debates so it's
good to see you just one on one uh and
we're going to come to Israel and we
come to the US election you of course
are running for president but first
let's talk about the Epstein Scandal
which every single day seems to produce
ever more lurid headlines what do you
make of it well it's important because
it's people in power that did terrible
things and seem to have largely gotten
away with it so I like that people care
about accountability on this issue the
problem is we don't really know exactly
who did it and exactly what they did so
you know you've got Bill Clinton saying
I was on the plane but I wasn't on the
island you got Richard Branson who's
come out vly denying there's any sex
tape of him as was supposedly revealed
uh yesterday uh there's lots of claim
counter claim going on very little hard
evidence which is indisputable which
could lead to
potential consequence yeah so when he
first died in in prison I thought okay
there's going to be something that's
determinative here did the video in the
hallway in the prison work or did it not
work if it worked and we see that no one
went into his cell okay then it's a
suicide I'm you know I don't I'm not
particularly fond of conspiracy theories
Etc but if it didn't work
okay well then that's a totally
different issue and as it turns out oh
golly gee the guards were off and the
video didn't work well that leads you to
many other speculation by nature of this
Beast right but look even Trump trump
said was terrific friends with Epstein
for a long long time and said he knows
that Epstein likes them young so there's
no question that he knew that Epstein
was up to terrible things
but did he do it I don't know it's easy
for the two sides to say Clinton
definitely did it Trump definitely did
it butal game playing going on with the
various names and different attitudes
depending if if it's one of your party
uh there's also I think with with the
Epstein Scandal a sense that you look at
it in totality you have Epstein who was
in jail and may have taken his own life
or may have had it taken from him we
probably never know the only other
person who's been brought to account is
gilay Maxwell his kind of Madame figure
in the whole thing none of the other men
who must have either known about
Epstein's proclivities or actively
joined him in some of them have ever
been properly brought to book for this
do you think they ever will well hard to
tell but one of the things that uh makes
me wonder and why I brought up the
videotape in the prison is because EP
was supposed to have videotapes of a lot
of this and yet we magically still
haven't found the vide tapes and uh
under the Bush Administration the guy
who let him go W up by the way being the
labor secretary for Trump he's the one
that let Epstein off the hook in the
first place right back in 2008 so
magically everyone keeps getting let off
the hook in this case except gain
Maxwell and of also it seems to me
there's sort of life before his first
conviction and life after it I before
the first conviction then you can
completely believe that people may have
been you know conned by this guy was a
big Finance guy you know there'd be no
reason potentially to know what he was
really like but once he had that
conviction in the early 2000s for you
know effectively a sex crime with a
minor you know pedophilia once that
happened everyone who then continued to
deal with him from prince Andrew onwards
uh they surely are culpable by
association yeah I think after 2008 you
have no excuses at all and and everybody
I I remember covering that story and and
I and I remember saying this is
ridiculous this is a slap on the wrist
for a guy who might have done an
enormous amount of pedophilia and been
connected to at the time we already knew
he was connected to tons of people in
finance politics people in power after
that going back and still associating
with them probably means you're an
addict probably means you you you you're
not only don't mind that at all but
can't help but go and seek that out and
what about that deal that was done at
that time I mean it was such
a murky Looking Back Now terrible deal
with the devil it seems yeah uh no
question and that that's what makes
people speculate so why are there are so
many conspiracy theories Now in America
because the people in power keep lying
and so they'll say things like oh money
in politics doesn't affect politicians
they take millions of dollars in
campaign contributions but they don't
they're not affected at all that's just
the Corporation is talking them it's
it's absurd and in the epine case you
have this guy who says oh this child
molester serial child molester is going
to serve a short time in prison but he's
not even really going to be in prison
he's going to get to go out during the
day and still conduct business and still
make a lot of money right which no other
prisoner gets almost no other prisoner
gets that privilege but since you're a
child molester wait you should have less
privileges not more privileges and it
was a joke of a sentence and at that
moment and everyone knew that the people
in power we didn't know who exactly and
why exactly but we knew that someone was
putting their thumb on the scale saying
do not prosecute this guy and remember
that was under a republican
Administration and a guy who was the
prosecutor there was rewarded later by
Trump and given a cabinet position will
it have any bearing on the election this
year probably not because a uh people on
both sides are implicated uh and of
course it's treated differently right
the Republicans think it's only
Democrats because they have a Mind
Freeze on anything that involves Trump
even though Trump says I was great
friends with him he's a terrific guy he
said back in the day and I knew that he
likes him young right they're like nope
I don't hear it I'm magga my brain is
frozen I don't listen to anything that's
anti-trump ever and the Democrats they
terrible at politics anyway they're not
going to be able to put it on Trump
there's a thousand things on Trump and
nothing ever sticks let's come to the
election you're running uh for president
I mean do you do you genuinely have any
belief you could win what is your real
purpose for running yeah so I have three
missions so let me tell you the first
one which is Joe Biden's going to lose
and I need to push him out he's at 33%
right now no one has ever recovered from
being that low as an incumbent for any
federal office let alone president he's
down 14 points with Independence he's
down four points with younger voters
he's down five points with Latinos it is
a disaster for Joe Biden and right now
now if we don't get him out we are
definitely going to lose to Donald Trump
he's losing every single swing state we
have to act now to get new candidates in
it is the Democratic party basically
saying we don't mind losing we're okay
with it Trump's going to take away
democracy that's okay and that's mission
number one he would say I beat him last
time yeah I would say you were 19 points
higher last time it is an insane
proposition to say that time has frozen
and four years ago is the same as today
it's like any
uh football team whether it's a you know
European football or American football
saying hey I was great four years ago so
I'm the only one that could beat the top
team now it makes no sense he's down 24
points uh uh if actually he's down way
more from his height uh he's down 10 14
points with Independence he's down a 33%
approval rating look Piers I can give
you 100 stats but the bottom line is no
one with an approval rating this low has
ever won for any federal office when
they were this far down in an election
season that means Joe Biden would have
to pull off the literally the greatest
political comeback in American history
does anyone in their right mind think
he's capable of that there's no way he
can do it so that's the number one
reason I'm in but there are two others
what are the other two so number two I'm
a naturalized citizen and uh there is
this mythology that you have to be
Natural Born to Run in America it is not
at all true it has been amended by the
14th amendment that says all persons
born or naturalized have due process and
equal protection and we're going to the
courts and in fact we have a hearing on
Wednesday in District Court in South
Carolina and we're going to prove that
this was already amended Out of You Want
To Make History definitely on the third
reason and the third reason is to win so
now you say well it's a long shot I
agree it's a long shot so how do you
where's the angle for possible Victory
here well you win the case uh in the
courts and people think well that's
Miracle number one one he was supposed
to not even have a chance he was
supposed to not be eligible but it turns
out we were wrong and he was right and
he did something that no one thought was
possible now I'm in the race officially
and legitimately according to everyone
right I I'm already in according to to
our argument and then they turn around
and start polling me well I know
oneon-one we did a poll already with
ugab legitimate poll that everybody else
uses oneon-one versus Biden I'm at 17
points so you're telling me I can't get
to 20 25 35 Etc I'm got a narrow window
I acknowledge that right but once we win
the case everything is eminently
possible how much of Biden's
unpopularity is specific to his age in
other words if he was a if he was Gavin
Nome who was currently the incumbent
president with the record that Biden has
had in the last three years would he be
polling much higher so yes and no uh a
lot has to do with his age 77% of
Americans have said said that they are
concerned that he will not be healthy
enough to finish a second ter now think
about that number that is over 34 of
Americans saying he's too old please
don't run him we're a vast majority of
Democrats including a huge percentage of
Democrats it is political malpractice to
run Biden when over three4 of the
country says I'm sorry but he's too old
but but is that the fact in other words
if you judged him purely on his record
which is what his Defenders say he's
actually done a pretty good job do you
buy into that no so that leads to the
second issue age is definitely an issue
whether we like it or not and you and
it's not just that he's old it's that he
looks an axe old you see Bernie Sanders
you see Donald Trump and they look
energetic I know people a lot older than
Joe Biden who are completely whip smart
uh he is not his actual age MC Jagger is
a few months difference in age and still
does two and a half hour shows every
night right I mean this idea that it's
just because he's 81 whatever it is that
that's for the birds it's it's actually
clearly he is disintegrating I mean to
be BR I mean look yes but here's the
thing Democrats get really upset when
you say that but it's not going to go
away doesn't mean it's not happening yes
and when you ask any real person in
America that is not involved in politics
what do you think of Joe Biden 100 out
of 100 says he's too old yeah that is
what they start with now but that is not
the only issue so in office how is he
done you know people say oh my God he he
did more than a normal Democratic
president that is a very low bar
democratic presidents barely try so did
he do most of his agenda no 85% of his
agenda is dead and there's no dispute
over that and the media says oh my God
he did 15% of his agenda what an
American hero I don't find that to be
heroic at all he said he' do the public
option he didn't even propose it he said
that he would uh do uh $15 minimum wage
he threw it under the bus in the very
first interview that he did he never
intended it paid family leave peers
pulls at 84% of America what kind of
politician are you if you can't get a
bill passed that pulls it
84% that's 74% among Republicans if you
can't get that passed honestly you suck
at politics let's talk about his
potential opponent if it ends up being a
Biden Trump rematch Biden's belief from
what I I hear is that he beat him before
and he can beat him again because the
anti-trump vote will come out and he may
have a point um
but it's incredible to people outside of
America that Donald Trump who lost last
time has been pretty much a consistent
loser in the electoral process since
2016 both in the midterms the general
elections Senate and so on that he's now
facing nearly a 100 criminal charges and
yet all that has done is fuel him and
make him more popular allow him to play
the victim and see his poll numbers go
up what does does that say about America
and geop political system no it says
something really important that media
almost never talks about to give you a
full context in one of the latest polls
Trump is up by eight against Biden and
remember the Democratic candidate must
win the popular vote by five points if
not they lose the Electoral College
Biden won by four and a half and nearly
lost only 44,000 votes and swing States
made the difference so you have to win
by five that means Biden is down by 13
to Donald Trump who is otherwise an
enormously unpopular candidate my God if
he was up against a popular candidate
he'd get Landslide it he might he might
get Walter Mandel then lose 49 stat is
one of the reasons that Trump is proving
so not just durable but potentially
going back to the White House that the
Democrats the liberal world for one of a
better phrase has overplayed its hand
and the reason I say that I remember in
2016 the very next day after that
election win I was in New York York went
to see the New York Knicks with my
eldest son and Chris Rock the comedian
was at the next table in this area we're
in and we got talking about the election
and he said you know the problem he said
if someone like Trump kills 10 people
don't go around saying he's killed 11 I
it was such a smart take on it in other
words we would say in England don't over
egg the sule don't exaggerate when you
have someone like Trump because it
allows him to say look at these people
they they've lost their minds they're
saying this when not true when in fact
there may be a good colel of Truth to go
him about have has the liberal world
overplayed through its demonic hatred of
trump has he overplayed its hand and
helped him yes and no so Donald Trump
reserves almost all the criticism that
he gets and he breaks so many laws that
he floods The Zone and then you don't
know what to respond to because he says
something maniacal here he broke that
law there he's a lifelong criminal Etc
but the number one issue is the one that
the media doesn't talk about which is
he's anti-establishment
that's why people like him is there a
portion of the Republican base that
likes the xenophobic racist sexist Etc
talk yes there is If you deny that
you're denying reality he can also be
let's be fair not to be fair let's be
accurate he could be genuinely funny I
mean if you watch his rallies it's like
watching a two-hour show yes you know
it's like watching AI a right-wing
version of Ricky jaase right so I see
that appeal he's he's a great performer
he's also Al I said Mr Jordan Peterson
uh on Monday he he has both the thinnest
skin of any human being I've ever met
and the thickest totally yes he reacts
to everything with Venom uh started
criticism bang bang bang bang bang but
he also can soak up incredible amounts
of pressure that would crush any other
candidate yeah so look makes him a
formidable politician oh he is no
question about it so Democrats
underestimate him at their Peril and
they don't over and over again so
there's three issues here one is yes he
did do all those things and sometimes
the Democrats overreach anyway right
number two is what you're pointing out
which is that he's telegenic he not in
terms of looks but in terms of he's
entertaining he's charismatic yes and
what Democrats don't understand is sorry
but politics is now all media Wars
that's what it is where do people get
the information on who they're going to
vote media some form of media not
necessarily mainstream media but some
form of media so you have to engage in
the media Wars and Trump is fantastic at
engaging in the media Wars he goes to
wherever the cameras are he grabs the
spotlight what does Biden do Biden made
his first speech against Trump just a
couple of days ago what are you waiting
for brother he's done 200 speeches in
the time that you've done one that is a
colossal media advantage and hence a
colossal political advantage and you're
not wrong often times he is both
wittingly and unwittingly funny so we
laugh at him all the time he says the
most absurd ridiculous things now but
the third part of it is he's giving a
giant middle finger to the establisher
and that is the largest reason for
his the popularity that he has he's
unpopular overall but among his base
it's less the xenophobic stuff it's yes
it's a little bit of entertainment but
mainly they love that finally someone
said well they've been dying to here
which is Screw The Establishment the
people in power have been totally
screwing you your whole life now the
Democratic party has people like that
like me but they never let them out they
say oh no you better not you better not
they establishment is beloved is it the
polling indicates that they hate you
they hate the politicians they hate
Congress they hate media but media goes
no they're wrong well of course you're
going to say that you're in the media
right so the Democrats have no idea
what's coming Piers look I said this
back in 2016 I went on ABC's this week
right after the DNC when Hillary was at
her height and I said Donald Trump's
going to win win now I don't want Donald
Trump to win I'm in this race event why
do I want to knock Biden out because I
don't want him to lose to Trump if Biden
is the candidate do you think Trump wins
if he wins the Republican nomination
it's near 100% so look and what would
that mean for America disaster total
epic disaster so let me break it down so
as I said earlier no candidate for any
federal office has ever come back from
this far down and Biden is losing all
seven swing States and he has to win by
five if you're an objective political
analyst there's no way in the world
anyone in their right mind could say
that he has anything approaching 50%
chance at Best in my opinion he has
about a 10% at best I've never seen
anyone do it and Biden refuses to
campaign so I think that if a strong
Third Party candidate comes in Biden
finishes third he has no support no base
whatsoever now he's losing young people
by four people people by Four Points
he's losing Latinos by five points for a
Democratic candidate totally utterly
untenable he is a guaranteed loss that's
why I'm in the race we have to push him
out otherwise we have no chance of
winning we're handing the country over
to Trump now to the second question so
how bad is that well Trump already tried
to CP so if Maga wants to catch feelings
over that they can go ahead and cry they
they love to cry oh we just violently
broke into the capital and had a fake
elector plot to steal democracy why are
you guys getting all bent out of shape
we're just trying to coup right and by
the way there guys on tape on January 6
going we're doing a revolution right
well imag imagine what they'll say if
Trump was to win and the Democrats
simply say we're not accepting it you
refuse to accept the result yeah of
course that is the consequence of not
accepting the result of democratic free
elections is that if you then end up
winning why should anyone else accept
your result so Piers the I'm going to
criticis for the Republicans and the
Democrats here so for the Republicans
remember the original idea that that
Trump had was Mike Pence cannot certify
the election and instead certify the
fake electors that they had ready right
well if that's true that Mike Pence
could do that then KLA Harris could do
of course so that means you know
according to Trump's logic and mag's
logic if there is such a thing that
means KLA Harris can just say I don't
care that Biden lost 28 States I don't
care if he lost 38 or 48 states I'm not
certifying it instead I'm certifying our
fake electors so they look the rightwing
in this country does not believe in
democracy they believe in power so they
believe it's our country and we will get
it by any means necessary we will take
it where okay so that's that's the
rightwing that's the disaster that
awaits us and and then the Democratic
party why did they wait two and a half
years to try to prosecute Donald Trump
they Meritt Garland should have gone on
day one when you wait for two and a half
years then the voters go wait you did it
just as he was running it seems
political even Republicans who don't
support Trump are now supporting him in
large numbers because they believe the
Democrats have overreached in the way
that he's being prosecuted and I can
understand that it's the same way they
Tred to take him off the ballot my first
reaction was why would you do that all
that does is make you more popular and
by the way the Supreme Court inevitably
will throw this out anyway so you won't
succeed all you'll succeed in doing is
making them even more popular yeah well
I mean look there's still folks uh that
I have a lot of adjectives for I'll try
to keep it under control that still say
indictments well all it's done has made
them more popular when are you going to
get it through your thick thick skull
that people don't think like you do so
this normal person who's a liberal in
Washington is like well I am outraged I
would never vote for anyone with 91
indictments yeah brother but you're not
the average voter the average voter
doesn't see it that way and hasn't seen
it that way and the polling has showed
it for nearly a year when is it going to
get through your incredibly thick head
by the way Piers there might be a disree
the you and I have which is that I think
almost all these cases are perfectly
legitimate as long as you did them in
the right time frame they should have
launched them the minute after the
election because there was law breaking
and you as a
you must pursue law breaking I think
some of it is clearly legitimate to go
after him over and we'll see whether it
leads to any convictions but when you
start with him paying off a porn star
for a secret night of passion behind his
wife's back and I think really is that
your starting point for going after
Donald Trump to me it trivialized it so
much in most people's eyes they were
like this looks pathetic I don't agree
at all and so yeah I don't and I'll tell
you why number one that is a clear
violation of the LA law and his
co-conspirator Michael Cohen already
went to prison for it so if we say
Michael Cohen should go to prison for it
but Donald Trump shouldn't because he's
Above the Law I think that's a terrible
I'm looking at what most average
Americans probably made of that and most
average Americans are like all right he
had a fling with a porn star behind his
wife's back he wants to keep it quiet he
pays her off they see payoffs all the
time in the world of entertainment media
politics and so on they read about this
stuff all the time it doesn't strike
them as either particularly shocking or
scandalous even if it may be illegal
yeah I I understand that that urge by
the average voter because they see all
these campaign contributions you know
millions of dollars hundreds of millions
of dollars that go into all these greasy
politicians hands and the media comes
out goes there's nothing wrong with it
nothing wrong with it at all they're
just talking right and it doesn't affect
the bills at all these are pure
honorable politicians so when they turn
around and say to Trump hey you're doing
something wrong by giving $150,000 to to
your mistress then it feels like that
it's wrong but on the law we have to
decide are we actually implementing the
law or are we saying that people in
power are the elites and let's be honest
magot if you don't get it by now the
reason why they didn't prosecute Trump
in the first place is because he's among
the elites and they were worried that if
they prosecuted him in the beginning
that the Republicans might prosecute
Biden and other people that's why they
waited two and a half years and then
they panicked they like oh no he's
running and he's popular and is Joe
Biden can't beat anyone it's super
obvious he can't beat anyone we have to
take everyone off the ballot take Trump
off the ballot and by the way they've
taken me off the ballot in a lot of
states and they've taken in four
American states in very important States
they have taken every Biden Challenger
off the ballot in the primaries and then
they turn around peers and say
democracy's on the line well if
democracy on the line you got a funny
way of showing yeah you don't fight
democracy be the line by thwarting
democracy exactly let's turn to Israel
and the war in Gaza we've had some very
emotive debates involving you and many
other people had a little break uh come
back now to see nothing's changed on the
ground perhaps the world's attention is
less obsessively now and there than it
was what is your take on where we are
with this war yeah so today we read that
uh that Israel is going to start to
withdraw a little bit from Gaza we'll
see I'll believe it when I see it uh is
Isel has been brutal uh they've now
killed about 20 times the number of
people that Hamas did uh I don't believe
that a state is immune from charges of
terrorism or genocide they say well
we're a state so we don't we can't when
we murder civilians it's perfectly
kosher sorry it isn't okay it it's just
as barbaric just as terrible tell me the
we've argued a lot about this tell me
the difference this is Playing devil's
Africa here yeah between going after
Isis in Iraq and Syria and eradicating
pretty much Isis but in the process
killing a lot of civilians and what
Israel is now doing with Hamas where
they believe they've killed maybe as
many as 10,000 Hamas terrorists which is
maybe a third of the total I mean I call
them terrorists because I believe
there's no other way to describe what
they did on October the 7th that's no
problem like I and I would argue that
Israel is taking terrorist which is
which is entirely your prog my point is
what's the what's the distinction in
your eyes morally between the deaths of
civilians when the world went after Isis
yeah in places like Iraq and Syria and
what's happened in Gaza yes so there's a
couple of really really important
differences so number one America even
when we were going after Isis even when
we were bogged down in mosul in the
biggest gorilla Warfare we've ever seen
within a city never Dropped a Bomb
bigger than 500 pounds because we
thought that's a war crime we can't go
above 500 lbs because that's
indiscriminate killing of civilians
Israel is dropping 2,000 lb bombs and a
lot of them are unguided what that means
is I don't give a damn who it kills I
don't care if it's a terrorist which by
the way are mainly under the tunnels
what I laughed at was the idea that they
killed 10,000 Hamas Fighters no one we
don't know we don't know No One Believes
I challenge the Israeli spokespeople
many times they don't know right they
they are they don't actually know any of
those stats right they believe that may
be the kind of ballpark figure it's not
being denied by h so you have to assume
it might be correct but even if it is
that still means there are maybe three
quter of Hamas left yeah so first of all
IDF has shown through their own videos
that the tunnels are largely intact we
know Hamas is in the tunnels so they in
all logic and evidence indicates that
they barely got any Hamas Fighters so
but okay whatever you've got Israeli
propaganda you got Hamas propaganda but
there's no question everyone agrees the
great majority of the people killed were
innocent civilians children and women
women largely so now in the Isis case
and it's been horrific I mean there's no
two ways of add it when you see these
scenes from Gaza the obliteration of
Northern Gaza the same now going on in
the South the fact that gaza's
population is half children the sheer
volume of children being killed on a
daily basis is utterly horrendous the
question becomes this is B question I've
raised many times from the start of this
war is after what Hamas did on October
the 7th what is morally justifiable in
terms of response by Israel and I don't
have the answer I'm just curious what
you think it is so number one it is not
indiscriminate killing of civilians and
that is almost certainly what we had in
Gaza uh 85% of Gaza gazans are now
homeless because 70% of the buildings
are either destroyed or damaged so what
they did was one of the biggest war
crimes we've ever seen in our life that
is not a proportional response I've said
on your show before I think they should
go with special forces you have to get
the hostages and I understand that
you've got to go after the Hamas
Fighters okay and that is fair if you
attack from your territory you should
expect Special Forces Back special
forces work they worked in the case of
Bin Laden and often times they worked in
the case of Isis we did not do giant
bombings of Iraq Syria Etc we had plenty
of war crimes on our hands too as
America executed the wars in Iraq and
Afghanistan but nothing on the scale of
what Israel's done to give you a sense
of it we killed less civilian is in 20
years in Afghanistan that Israel killed
in two months in Gaza so they are
dropping they dropped 29,000 bombs in a
size in a city the size of Las Vegas the
sheer Terror of that is Indescribable so
you send in Special Forces you do
something but most importantly this goes
to your question about how is it
different than Isis and how to resolve
it Isis doesn't represent anyone Isis
doesn't represent a ethnic group they
claim they represent a religious group
but they are radicals and they don't
represent at Muslims at all in general
right but Hamas is fighting a war
because of the occupation and the
occupation of the Palestinians is
untenable so every day that you have an
occupation you're going to have a
resistance and it's undeniable that
there been occation yeah and we know
that because when this war latest War
started the fact that Israel was able to
turn on the Taps of energy and water
fuel and so on the fact they could do
that stop the food coming in and out
that is what an occupation involves it
means you control somewhere which is not
legally yours to control and you're
controlling it so I don't think you can
argue whoever besid you come down on
this you can't argue against the idea
there's been an occupation nor can you
argue that a lot of the more right-wing
members of netanyahu's cabinet some of
whom are extreme far right people uh
that they have no concern about what is
happening and would be quite happy to
see all 2 million Palestinians gone um
and they they would love to just take
that land now that's also undeniable
which is one of the reasons why
Netanyahu has dug himself into a very
difficult position politically I think
for his own future but by packing Miss
cabinet with all these hard right people
uh purely to get himself elected prime
minister again he now finds himself at
their their under their control yeah
there's no question about a whole heap
of talking points that we hear non-stop
in America
some people do sophistry and say well is
it technically apartheid technically
occupation what difference does it make
as you point out they control those
areas those are open air prisons they
can cut off the water power electricity
anytime they want the Palestinians can't
control their own borders it's obviously
oppression by any name and then they say
oh Hamas uses human Shields well they
live in an area that is filled with
civilians that you keep in an open air
prison so uh it doesn't make doesn't
mean Hamas don't use them as human
Shields I don't actually think Hamas has
shown by its behavior in the last 17
years where they've had power in Gaza
that they have any real concern for the
welfare of Palestinians no I I don't
think they do Hamas is Muslim
fundamentalists and so whenever you have
oppression unfortunately fundamentalism
grows that's a great breeding can't be a
future with aass in charge can they yeah
I don't think so no so who I mean let's
cut to the quick here about How This
Ends people talk about the day after the
war how do you think this ends and what
is the smartest way for everyone to go
forward when the war is over so let let
me handle that in two ways the current
path that Israel is on is uh well Hamas
made us kill all your kids that's an
absurd thing to claim if you're so
powerful why is Hamas making you kill
their civilians that's absurd and then
they say oh we're going to the war ends
when Hamas surrenders nobody thinks
they're going to surrender that's an
absurd standard what are they going to
say okay I'm right here come and bomb me
come and arrest me so there but there is
a real way that it can end so you make a
deal with the Palestinian Authority and
the Biden Administration has finally
woken up and begun to go in this
direction they are totally discredited
riddle with corruption that's right but
I'll I'll tell you how you fix that
problem it's it's in one bundle it's
actually relatively straightforward you
take the Palestinian Authority which you
are right is reputationally damaged not
just in Israel but more importantly with
the pales
for collaborating with Israel for all
this time for the occation you make a
peace deal with them you give you do the
two-state solution now now right now not
20 years from now not after 50 years
more of occupation you do it now and you
do it with the Palestinian Authority
that then buys them The credibility to
be able to go and control Gaza if they
go into Gaza now they look like
collaborators but if they go into Gaza
with a peace deal and say we got a
Palestinian State then they have enough
credibility to be able ble to control
Gaza and the West Bank and be a real
partner for peace peers you know that
isn't the real problem a boss would
probably do that deal in a minute that's
a Lifeline for him and he gets to be a
hero Netanyahu says I don't want the
deal he said I'm so proud that I blocked
the Palestinian State and I'm going to
keep on blocking it so there is one
person totally responsible for the
Carnage Benjamin
n i mean I would say Hamas is also
responsible I would say that yah who is
very damaged he may not survive this
himself and he is at the beest now and
under control of his right-wing cabinet
which is incredibly unfortunate for
those like you and I who would like to
see peace be achieved here how long do
you think this war is going to go on for
so we have a problem with n on our
second front which is that he's corrupt
he has these charges he's lost the
Israel population and I don't want
people making assumptions about Israel
and the people that live there look at
how unpop Netanyahu is with his own
population right and there is there is
no democracy in Israel overall because
they imprison 5 million Palestinians but
there is democracy within Israel itself
for them right and within that democracy
you have a vibrant media Etc that
criticizes Netanyahu so the reason why I
say Netanyahu is primarily responsible
is because even if you blame Hamas and
that's fair well he's the one that aided
and embedded Hamas he's the one that
helped them get funding he's the one
that thought it was a brilliant idea to
have them as a counterweight to the
Palestinian Authority the fact it
fractured the Palestinian politic
exactly he's the one that let his guard
down on October 7th and he was busy
helping the settlers oppress the
Palestinians and the West Bank and
didn't help his people but since the
only thing that keeps him in power
especially at this point in time is the
war he has a built-in incentive to never
end the war so somehow the Israeli
population has to re gain control of
their government and you know in a
parliamentary system that's easier than
in a presidential system and so they've
got to call for an election and they've
got to get the guy out right now hey
we're going to get him out after the war
means that you're going to have endless
war but the problem is the polls show
that whilst there's a lot of
unpopularity for
Netanyahu and he would certainly lose an
election if it was held tomorrow on that
basis and L of it's driven by they blame
him for what happened on October the 7th
there's also widespread support in
Israel for what the IDF are doing in
terms of response so you have these two
things running concurrently Netanyahu
personally very unpopular but what the
IDF are doing under his command as prime
minister is very popular yeah so look
there's two issues one is Nyah is in
charge and is and we don't have
elections and we can't get him out even
though the Israelis want him second want
him to get out the second issue is
you're right it's not just Netanyahu
problem it's an Israeli right-wing
problem and right now the rest of his
cabinet is a bunch of monsters ghouls
and goblins who are openly brazenly
talking about ethnically cleansing the
Palestinians in ways that are are
sometimes even more vicious than
Netanyahu and talking about starting a
war in Lebanon starting a war in Iran
that is insanity Total Insanity so look
at some point if the Israeli population
does not choose peace we're all doomed
for endless war in the Middle East but
if the Israeli population in an election
chooses peace for the first time since
the itak Rin then all of this can be
solved and relatively quickly Saudi
Arabia still says they want to do an
agreement with is is tons most of the
Middle East wants to do a deal with
Israel and the and Palestinian Authority
wants to do a deal with Israel the
people blocking that is the right-wing
government of Israel get in a moderate
government in Israel and we can end this
thing forever Jake great to see you all
right great to see you really good to to
chat over the issues I wish you all the
best for 2024 thank
you